rejoignez-moi sur patreon pour accéder à
l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des courants visx des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur patreon le
lien est dans la
description Le 17 Avril 2011 la chaîne
amerriicain HBO diffuse le premier
épisode d'une série qui marquera en
profondeur l'histoire de la télévision
Game of Thrones inspiré des romans de
George r Martin Game of Thrones nous
plonge dans l'univers fascinant de West
Eros un continent déchirés par les
guerres les trahisons et les luttes pour
le pouvoir ancré dans un Moyen-Âge
mythique la série déconcertte par ses
moyens colossaux et son rapport
décomplexé à la violence au sexe et à la
politique elle contribuera à redéfinir
les codes de la narration audiovisuelle
n'hésitant pas à faire mourir ses
personnages principaux ou à brouiller
notre perception du bien et du mal on se
surprend à avoir de l'empathie pour un
personnage qu'on détestait on se
surprend à souhaiter la mort d'un
personnage qu'on admirait mais derrière
la puissance narrative de Game of
Thrones le spectateur attentif n'aura
pas manqué d'entrevoir la dimension
philosophique de la série qui explore de
manière subtille les thèmes de
l'ambition de l'identité de l'amour et
de l'affiliation le sang et les dragons
ne sont pas seulement là pour le
divertissement ils sont le support
d'expression d'un voyage au cœur de
l'âme humaine dans cet épisode nous
allons faire l'analyse de SEP
personnages de Game of Thrones SEP
personnages qui chacun à leur manière
incarne un idéal et une éthique
philosophique cette analyse n'a pas la
prétention de faire la lumière sur les
intentions cachées des auteurs de la
série elle se veut un simple aperçu de
la dimension philosophique de l'œuvre
vous permettant de constater que
derrière chaque personnage chaque
réplique ou chaque plan de caméra une
vision du monde est à l'œuvre libre à
vous ensuite de construire votre propre
interprétation et de la partager en
commentaire vous êtes prêts alors c'est
parti premier personnage Arya Stark Arya
est le personnage typique du roman
d'initiation âgé d'une dizaine d'années
au début de la série le spectateur suit
son évolution jusqu'à l'âge adulte une
évolution qui prendra des allures de
métamorphose fille cadette de net Stark
le trèsloyal gouverneur du Nord Arya ne
se reconnaît pas dans le rôle trad
ellement assigné aux femmes alors que sa
sœur Sansa rêve de romance et de robe de
princesse Arya est plus à l'aise avec un
arc ou une épée dans les mains ce
tempérament de garçon manqué constituera
même un rouage scénaristique de la série
puisque quand elle sera obligée de
dissimuler son identité Arya se fera
passer pour un garçon comme pour mieux
souligner la dualité qui habite le
personnage la trajectoire d'Aria bascule
le jour où elle assiste impuissante à la
mise à mort de son père accusé à tort de
trahison contre le roi net Stark refuse
d'avouer sa culpabilité pour un crime
qu'il n'a pas commis mais lorsqu'il
aperçoit Arya dans la foule son amour
pour sa fille le pousse finalement à
faire de faux aveux convaincu que le roi
annulera sa condamnation et qu'ainsi
Arya ne grandira pas avec la vision de
son père décapité c'était sans compter
sur la perversion sadique du roi Joffrey
qui se délectera des aveux de Ned avant
de confirmer l'exécution à partir de cet
instant la métamorphose d'Aria est
enclenchée
réduite à la clandestinité puisqu'elle
est officiellement la fille d'un traître
elle entame un périple au cours duquel
elle devra non seulement survivre mais
aussi dompter le désir de vengeance qui
brûle en elle Arya a non seulement vu
son père être décapité mais elle l'a
surtout vu renier son honneur pour elle
et pour un Stark renier son honneur est
une chose bien pire que la mort Arya n'a
plus rien à perdre son objectif tuer
tous ceux qui ont participé de près ou
de loin au meurtre de son père
elle s'adonne même à un rituel chaque
soir avant de s'endormir elle énonce à
voix haute la liste de toutes les
personnes qu'elle doit tuer une liste
qui ne cesse de s'allonger au fil des
épisodes saison après saison Arya gagne
en maturité et en efficacité son audace
et son assurance sont inversement
proportionnels au danger qu'elle inspire
à première vue quand ses ennemis
regardent Arya il voit un être
inoffensif quand elle dégagne son épée
il voit la mort déguisée en enfant mais
même le très effrayant Sandor klegan dit
le limier reconnaîtra qu'il n'aimerait
pas être à la place des ennemis d'Aria
lui que tout le monde redoute alors que
la jeune Stark le défie ouvertement Arya
évolue en parallèle de la trame
principale de Game of Thrones la plupart
des péripéties qu'elle traverse n'ont
pas de lien direct avec le cœur de
l'intrigue bien qu'elle soit d'une
importance cruciale dans la résolution
de cette dernière tandis que toute sa
famille est en guerre Arya prépare son
retour et à mesure qu'elle affronte des
adversaires de plus en plus menaçant
elle devient de plus en plus aguérie
tout ce qui ne te tue pas te rend plus
fort disait Nietzsche pour Arya chaque
hématome est une leçon la qualité d'Arya
Stark c'est l'audace sa philosophie la
vengeance sa devise Valar morgouis tout
homme doit mourir en sanscrit Arya
signifie honorable ce qui fait
évidemment écho au désir de la jeune
fille de rétablir l'honneur de son père
et dans la mythologie grecque hares est
le dieu de la guerre qui donnera mars
chez les Romains tous les éléments
convergent donc vers l'idée cararya a
été programmé pour devenir une guerrière
formé à l'art du combat Arya apprend à
compenser son manque de puissance par
son agilité une qualité qui deviendra
son atout dans un monde où la plupart
des guerriers ont l'habitude de tout
miser sur la force de son maître de
danse Sirio Farel elle apprendra ce
qu'on doit dire au dieu de la mort quand
il vient nous chercher pas aujourd'hui
et au côté de jackenagar elle a
apprendra à devenir une sans visage
c'est-à-dire à perdre son identité
n'être plus personne pour pouvoir
devenir n'importe qui Arya était déjà un
personnage ambivalent la voilà désormais
insaisissable dans les deux sens du
terme ce n'est pas pour rien si
l'accessoire préféré d'Arya et son
Fleuré qu'elle baptisera aiguille en
référence à son allure inoffensive la
finesse de sa lame est une métaphore de
sa fugacité de même que son apparente
fragilité dissimule une résistance
insoupçonnée et de la même façon que son
épée s'éguise au fil des combats la
vision du monde d'ya s'éguise avec
l'expérience à la fin de son
apprentissage Arya n'est plus une enfant
mais une guerrière une guerrière qui
aura débarrassé son peuple de son ennemi
le plus menaçant les marcheurs blanc et
qui une fois la paix revenue sur le
royaume fera le choix de le quitter pour
continuer ses aventures sous d'autres
cieux consciente que la vie est un
voyage sans fin et que l'inconnu est sa
meilleure
boussole
deuxème personnage Peter bilish dit
Littlefinger Peter bilish est un
personnage énigmatique à la fois
trésorier du roi et gérant d'une maison
close celui qu'on surnomme Littlefinger
cultive le paradoxe quand il prend la
parole difficile de démêler le vrai du
faux la seule chose dont on soit certain
c'est qu'il ne dit jamais rien au hasard
chacune de ses déclarations est pesée et
s'inscrit dans une stratégie conçue pour
le faire gagner car la seule chose à
laquelle bish accorde la
c'est la défense de ses intérêts little
finger n'est ni bon ni mauvais il est
amoral il n'éprouve pas de haine
particulière contre les gens pas plus
qu'il ne se montre bienfaisant s'il n'a
quelque chose à y gagner tel un joueur
d'échec tous ses coups sont calculés et
à chaque fois qu'un sourire apparaît sur
son visage on comprend que dans son
esprit il mène une bataille
contrairement à la plupart des autres
personnages pour qui la guerre fait
partie du quotidien bish n'a jamais tenu
une épée son arme à lui ce sont les mots
et la seule fois où il tue quelqu'un de
ses mains c'est sa propre femme
lorsqu'elle s'interpose entre lui et
celle qu'il cherche à conquérir Sansa
Sansa est la fille aînée de Ned et de
kitlyn Stark or bish a toujours été
amoureux de kitlyn sa fille sa est un
rappel de cet amour la version jeune
mais surtout innocente et manipulable de
celle qu'il n'a jamais cessé de
convoiter raison pour laquelle bish fera
en sorte jour aès jour de créer des
occasions de rapprochement avec la jeune
Stark assurant qu'il veut seulement la
protéger mais cherchant en réalité à la
placer sous son influence et à la
façonner à sa guise un Pigma lion d'une
redoutable intelligence peut-être un peu
trop pour inspirer la confiance le
talent de Peter bilish c'est la
manipulation sa philosophie le niilisme
sa devise le chaos est une échelle
derrière son raffinement apparent ce que
Little finger aime par-dessus tout c'est
le désordre plus précisément créer le
désordre car le désordre qu'on crée est
un désordre qu'on maîtrise quand la
plupart des gens voient le chaos comme
un abîme bish le voit comme une échelle
entendez comme un moyen d'asscension
vers le pouvoir car le chaos permet de
semer le trouble de révéler les
impostures et de déjouer les plans qui
s'échafaudent dans l'ombre à l'instar de
machavel Littlefinger sait que la guerre
est d'abord une affaire de psychologie
et que le plus sûr moyen de triompher
c'est de désorienter l'adversaire du
chaos Dieu fait naître l'ordre du
désordre l'homme fait naître le pouvoir
Littlefinger ne croit en rien si ce
n'est en lui-même imperméable à toute
forme de transcendance sa double
fonction de proxénet et de trésorier
symbolise les deux seules choses qui à
ses yeux ont un réel impact sur le monde
le sexe et l'argent entre les deux le
pouvoir il y a deux sortes s d'homme
dira beish les joueurs et les pièces
ironie du sort c'est Sansa qui fera
exécuter bish au moment même où il
croyait être parvenu à asseoir son
emprise sur elle elle le remerciera
d'ailleurs pour ses nombreuses leçons
dont cell qui lui aura été fatale il n'y
a pas de justice dans ce monde à moins
de la rendre
nous-mêm trè personnage Jamy lanister au
début de game of Thrones le royaume de
West hér est entre les mains de Robert
Barathéon un souverain vieillissant
davantage porté sur le vin et sur les
prostituées que sur l'art de gouverner
Robert Barathéon a pour femme cerseille
lanister et ensemble ils ont trois
enfants Joffrey mircella et thmen ça
c'est pour la version officielle des
choses mais la réalité c'est que la
reine cerseille entretient depuis
toujours une relation incestueuse avec
son frère jumeau jimie et que les trois
enfants qu'elle a mis au monde n'ont pas
pour géniteur Robert Barathon mais Jamie
la relation interdite entre Jamie et
cerse constitue le point d'origine de
l'intrigue de Game of Throne surpris
pendant un rapport sexuel avec sa sœur
par le jeune Bran Stark Jamie le pousse
dans le vide persuadé que l'enfant
n'aura pas survécu à la chute et
qu'ainsi le secret restera intact mais
contre toute attente Bran est toujours
vivant et s'entame alors une guerre
larvée entre les Starks et les lanister
après son geste jimie n'éprouve aucun
remord son seul regret c'est de ne pas
avoir réussi à tuer le jeune Bran lui
qui passe pour être l'un des meilleurs
tueurs de West aos dépourvu de toute
morale sa seule obsession est cerseille
pour laquelle il éprouve une passion
dévorante incapable de refrainer son
désir pour sa sœur chaque entrevue avec
elle donne lieu à une lutte intérieure
entre passion et raison et chez Jimy la
passion l'emporte souvent sur la raison
pour preuve cette scène qui a choqué les
spectateurs du monde entier alors que
leur fils Geoffrey vient d'être
assassiné et que cerseille pleure sur sa
dépouille Jamie la viole sur l'hôtel
ajoutant à la transgression du tabou de
l'inceste l'obscénité d'une relation
sexuelle en présence de leur enfant mort
Jamie lanister est l'archétype du
personnage conçu pour être détesté
arrogant méprisant dénué de toute
compassion et de tout sens de l'honneur
Jamie n'inspire qu'antipathie et
pourtant la suite des événements va nous
obliger à réviser notre
jugement ce qui anime Jamie lanister
c'est la passion sa philosophie le
cynisme sa devise que ne ferait-on pas
par amour Jamie lanister est surnommé le
régicide car il est l'assassin du
précédent roi iris targarien dit le roi
fou Jamie ne sera jamais condamné pour
ce meurtre et pour cause il a commis au
moment même où Robert Barathéon le futur
roi lançait un siège contre targarien
autant dire que grâce à
le trône était libre mais une
information va venir modifier notre
lecture des événements dans l'épisode 5
de la saison 3 on apprend que si Jimy a
tué le roi fou ce n'est pas par instinct
meurtrier mais parce que le roi avait
prévu de mettre le feu à sa propre ville
autrement dit c'est pour empêcher la
mort de dizaines de milliers d'innocents
que Jamie est intervenu celui qu'on
appelle le régicide devrait donc en
réalité être appelé le Sauveur et si
Jamie n'a jamais cherché à rétablir la
vérité c'est parce qu'il est indifférent
à ce que les gens pensent de lui comme
le dit son père Tywin le Lion ne se
préoccupe pas de l'opinion des moutons
pourquoi chercher la reconnaissance d'un
peuple qu'on méprise jimie ne cherche
pas à être reconnu il cherche à être
redouté et quel meilleur moyen d'être
redouté que de laisser les gens penser
qu'on a tué un roi au fil des saisons le
personnage de Jamie évolue et cette
évolution on la doit à un autre
personnage féminin de la série Brienne
de torse
Brien est la parfaite antithèse de
cerseille combattante loyale vierge
Brien a fait le serment de protéger les
filles Stark avec lesquels jimie est en
guerre et pourtant c'est au contact de
Brien que jimie abandonnera peu à peu
son cynisme et finira même par se
comporter en homme honorable alors qu'il
est le prisonnier de Brien et qu'il a
donc tout intérêt à lui nuire il empêche
des mercenaires de la violer allant
jusqu'à se faire couper la main pour
s'être interposé quand cerseille accuse
leur frère Tyrion du meurtre de leur
fils jimie l'aide à s'enfuir convaincu
qu'il n'est pas l'assassin et lorsque
les marcheurs blancs menacent la
sécurité des Nordiens il abandonne son
armée pour leur prêter main forte jimie
aime cerseille par-dessus tout sa
passion pour elle est au-delà de toute
morale au-delà de toute raison sa
lucidité sur ce point ne fait aucun
doute elle est taissable et pourtant je
l'aime cersille à beauêtre l'encre qui
le tire vers les prof fondeur elle est
aussi l'étoile qui dirige sa marche
jamie a aimé Brien mais pas au point de
faire une croix sur cerseille pas au
point de faire passer la raison avant la
passion 4e personnage Tyrion lanisterè
Tyrion est le jeune frère de Jamie
eterseille surnommé le gnome en raison
de son anisme toute la vie de Tyrion fut
marquée par les railleries et les
humiliations son propre père lui dira
les yeux dans lesux qu'il a toujours
souhaité sa mort coupable malgré lui de
la perte de sa femme morte en le mettant
au monde mais il en fallait plus pour
ébranler l'instinct de survie de Tyrion
inapte au combat c'est par son
intelligence qu'il va gagner sa place
dans l'entourage des rois
particulièrement doué dans l'art de
l'éloquence vif d'esprit et doté d'un
redoutable sens de la psychologie Tyrion
doit ses talents à sa diffformité car
c'est elle qui l'a poussé depuis
l'enfance à affuter son intelligence
dans les livres et dans l'observation
des comport humains comme il le confiera
à John snow mon frère a son épée et moi
j'ai mon esprit Tyon comprend les
faibles les esclaves les bâtards les
marginaux les gens brisés parce qu'il en
fait partie et cette compréhension lui
permet de savoir mieux que quiconque
comment se comporter face à l'humain
quand la cité royale est assiégée c'est
lui qui a l'idée d'utiliser le feu
grégeois pour neutraliser la flotte
ennemie quand deneris veut éliminer les
esclavagistes c'est lui qui préconise
une approche diplomatique pour qu'elle
conserve son aura de libératrice et si
son nom n'apparaît pas dans le livre qui
raconte l'histoire de cette guerre c'est
pour mieux souligner son statut d'homme
de l'ombre car en devenant le plus
proche conseiller des gouvernants il est
devenu sans même le vouloir celui qui
gouverne la qualité de Tyrion
lanisterère c'est l'intelligence sa
philosophie l'influence sa devise je
bois et je sais des choses le penchant
de Tyrion pour l'alcool et les
prostituées est un rappel de sa
condition de malaimer et donc de son
besoin de réconfort autrefois marié il
finira par apprendre que sa prétendu
femme était en réalité une prostituée
payée par son père dans le but de
l'humilier cet événement sera si
traumatisant pour lui qu'il refusera
longtemps que l'on évoque le sujet en sa
présence boire et fréquenter les maisons
closes sont les seuls moyens qu'il ait
trouvé pour se persuader que tout ce
qu'il désire c'est vivre une vie de
plaisir éphémère lorsque Tyrion tombe à
nouveau amoureux d'une prostituée Chae
et que pour ne rien faciliter celle-ci
tombe amoureuse de lui en retour il
décide finalement de renoncer à elle
encore marqué par le traumatisme de son
premier mariage le destin lui fera payer
sa décision le prix fort puisque cette
rupture conduera Chae dans les bras de
taiwin le père de Tyrion qui dans un
accès de colère étranglera Chae avant de
tuer son père son sens de la psychologie
Tyrion le père dès qu'il est face à une
femme qu'il aime il en aura à la la
tragique confirmation lorsqu'il
accordera une confiance aveugle à
deseris ne voyant pas que celle-ci est
en train de sombrer dans la folie allant
même jusqu'à faire condamner son ami
varis pour avoir tenté de lui ouvrir les
yeux Tyrion fait partie des personnages
les plus intelligents de Game of Throne
mais son intelligence ne l'amènera
jamais à convoiter le trône peut-être
est-ce justement son intelligence qui
l'en préserva car quand on connaît le
destin habituellement réservé au monarqu
comment vouloir devenir roi quand on
aime autant la
vie 5e personnage cerseille
lanisterè marié au roi Robert Barathéon
cerseil lanister n'éprouve plus aucun
amour pour son mari son seul désir c'est
de placer son fils aîné sur le trône
Joffrey le jour où Robert part à la
chasse et qu'il en revient mortellement
blessé par un sanglier on comprend
immédiatement que cerseille n'est pas
étrangère à cet accident ce qui se
confirmera par la suite cerseille avait
demandé à l'un des écuyers du roi de
faire en sorte qu'il ne manque pas de
vin altérant ainsi sa vigilance et le
rendant vulnérable à l'attaque d'un
animal tout se passa comme elleavait
prévu Joffrey devint roi et quant à elle
elle pouvait continuer à tirer les
ficelles du royaume tout en se faisant
passer pour une pauvre reine uillée mais
surtout en provoquant la mort de Robert
cerseil venait sans que personne ne le
sache de transférer le pouvoir des mains
des barathéons à celle des lanisterè
puisque comme on l'a vu ses enfants ne
sont pas de Robert mais de jimie bien
qu'il fut de courte durée le règne de
Joffrey permit de révéler le caractère
impitoyable de cerseille se livrant aux
pires atrocités sur T ceux qui osent
contester son autorité ou même
simplement sur ceux dont il estime que
la vie n'a aucune valeur Joffrey n'en
conserve pas moins le soutien et l'amour
de sa mère comme Jamie le disait déjà à
son propos cerseille a beau savoir que
son fils est un monstre elle l'aime d'un
amour inconditionnel car il est le
prolongement d'elle-même
sa famille est la seule chose qui compte
pour cerseille famille n'est d'ailleurs
pas le mot qui convient le mieux quand
on voit avec quel mépris elle considère
son frère Tyon qu'elle fera condamnée à
mort pour un crime qu'il n'a pas commis
ou encore l'explosion du Grand Septuaire
qu'elle orchestrera pour se débarrasser
d'un groupe de fanatiques religieux au
cours de laquelle sa belle-fille perdra
la vie ce qui entraînera le suicide de
son deuxième fils forcé par le grand
moine à accomplir une marche de la honte
pour expier ses péchés cerseille s'était
retrouvé humilié c'est cette humiliation
qui l'a conduite à planifier l'explosion
du Septuaire pour assouvir sa vengeance
car quand cerseille est attaqué dans sa
personne elle n'a aucune limite la
particularité de cerseil lanister c'est
la fierté sa philosophie l'égoïsme sa
devise plus tu aimeras de gens plus tu
seras faible si jimie est prêt à tout
sacrifier par amour pour cerseille
cerseille est prête à tout sacrifier par
amour pour elle-même son amour pour ses
enfants est lui-même ambigu tout se
passe comme si ceux qui s'en prennent à
eux s'en prenaient en fait à elle elle
ne défend pas ses enfants par instinct
maternel mais par ego et du suicide de
tomun à la condamnation à mort de Tyrion
en passant par la torture de la femme
qui a tué sa fille tout porte à croire
qu'à chaque fois ce ne sont pas ses
enfants qu'elle venge mais son honneur
personnel le fait que ses enfants aient
été conçus avec son frère qui plus est
avec son frère jot fournit une
explication à ce mélange d'amour et
d'égoïsme en effet le sang de ses
enfants c'est le sang des laanistère à
100 %. et en tant que frère jumeau Jimy
représente la version masculine de
cerseille sa moitié dans le mythe des
androgyes de Platon il est rapporté
qu'en des temps anciens les êtres
humains étaient doubles à la fois hommes
et femmes en les coupant en deux Dieu
les a condamné à passer le restant de
leur existence à rechercher le leur
moitié manquante une punition qui serait
l'origine de l'amour si on comprend ça
on comprend l'amour fusionnel qui unit
jy à cerseille et le fait que la lignée
de cette dernière constitue pour elle
une extension de sa propre personne
ainsi à chaque fois qu'elle perd un de
ses enfants cerseille perd une partie
d'elle-même lorsqu'elle apprend qu'elle
est à nouveau enceinte de jimie
l'égoïsme de cerseille se radicalise au
point de lui faire perdre tout sens des
réalités elle contemple impassible la
destruction de sa cité par deneris
convaincu jusqu'au bout qu'elle gagnera
quand même sa guerre contre elle ses
plus proches conseillers se rendent bien
compte que cerseille est dans le dénis
mais ce dénis est en réalité la marque
de son indifférence à tout ce qui ne la
concerne pas directement le monde peut
bien être mis à feu et à sang avait-elle
prévenu la seule chose qui compte c'est
ce qu'il y a dans mon ventre
Schopenhauer disait qu'avoir des enfants
était un moyen de survivre à sa propre
mort d'accéder en somme à l'immortalité
en mourant sous les décombres de son
donjon dans les bras de Jamie venu pour
la sauver cerseille emporte avec elle la
dernière vie qui aurait pu la faire
accéder à l'immortalité
elle aura néanmoins remporté sa guerre
personnelle celle de n'avoir offert à
personne le plaisir de la
tuer 6e personnage John snow dès la
première saison de Game of Thrones le
spectateur comprend que Jon Snow est un
personnage avec qui il faudra compter
fils illégitime de Ned Stark ce qui lui
vaut d'être surnommé le bâtard Jon Snow
s'est toujours considéré comme un Stark
c'est pourquoi quand son frère Rob part
en guerre contre les lanister John ne
désire qu'une chose combattre à ses
côtés pour défendre l'honneur de la
famille mais un autre engagement l'en
empêchera membre de la garde de nuit il
a prêté serment de ne jamais quitter ses
frères d'armes et John est un homme de
parole
tout au long de la série John snow aura
à composer avec le fait que le devoir
exige parfois des choses contradictoires
et que servir une cause c'est être
obligé de renoncer à une autre John n'a
pas peur de mourir pas plus qu'il ne se
soucie du jugement des autres sur lui
preuve de son intégrité il est le seul à
témoigner du respect à Samuel tarli
moqué pour sa corpulence et son
incompétence au combat Sam se révélera
pourtant d'une aide cruciale dans la
guerre contre les marcheurs blancs dont
il découvrira le point faible John a
beau être un extraordinaire combattant
il est conscient que la valeur d'un
homme ne se résume pas à ça et que
derrière chaque bonne volonté il y a une
force à exploiter la caractéristique de
Jon Snow c'est la loyauté sa philosophie
le devoir sa devise l'amour et la mort
du devoir John snow ne s'intéresse pas
aux femmes conscient intuitivement que
l'amour est ce qui détourne l'homme de
sa mission il en fera l'expérience avec
igrit la sauvageun au cheveux roux dont
il refusera longtemps les avances
indifférent au pouvoir dépourvu de tout
préjugés et de tout ressentiment John
Snow est l'incarnation du héros au cœur
pur ressuscité du royaume des morts la
référence christique est à peine voilée
John fait passer l'intérêt des siens
avant la gloire et non seulement il ne
recherche pas le pouvoir mais il le
refuse même quand son peuple lui offre
sur un plateau les choses vont basculer
le jour où John va faire la rencontre de
deneris c'est la fille d'iris targarien
le roi fou tué par Jimy à ce titre elle
revendique le trône de Westeros récupéré
par Robert Barathéon puis par les
lanister elle va alors solliciter
l'appui de Jn snow dont elle connaît les
relations pour le moins conflictuelles
avec les lanisterè John accepte mais à
une condition que deneris l'aide à
éliminer les marcheurs blancs un peuple
de morts vivants qui menace directement
sa région chevauchant ses dragons
deneris et John s'envolent vers le nord
et et viennent à bout des marcheurs
blancs à l'issue d'une bataille aussi
angoissante que sublime John et deneris
tombent amoureux et si leur priorités ne
sont pas les mêmes devenir reine pour
deneris protéger son peuple pour John
ils sont néanmoins d'accord sur le fait
qu'une alliance leur serait profitable
leur mariage n'est plus qu'une question
de temps mais un événement inattendu va
venir créer une faille dans leur idyle
en effet John découvre qu'il n'est pas
le fils de net Stark mais de regar
targarien le frère aîné de deneris
autrement dit John Snow est le neveu de
deneris si Jamie et cerseille
entretiennent une relation incestueuse
volontaire John et deneris l'ignoraient
tous les deux mais au-delà du tabou
familial lorsque deneris apprend la
nouvelle c'est une autre chose qui
l'inquiète le souverain légitime de
Westeros ne serait en réalité pas elle
mais John ce dernier beau lui répéter
qu'il n'est pas intéressé par le trône
rien n'y fait deneris n'a plus confiance
John snow se retrouve alors prisonnier
d'un inextricable dilemme l'amour ou le
devoir sa dévotion à deneris ou la
volonté de son peuple et du destin que
ce soit lui le roi de Westeros coincé
entre deux impératifs irréconciliable
John snow va devoir faire un choix un
choix parfaitement résumé par Tyon qui
lui rappelle que si l'amour et la mort
du devoir il se pourrait bien que le
devoir soit la mort de
l'amour
7e personnage daeris
targarien davantage encore que John snow
daeris apparaît immédiatement comme un
personnage à part dans la série alors
que tous les personnages de Game of
Thrones ont au moins en commun de vivre
sur le même continent West heros les
aventures de deneris se déroulent
essentiellement sur le continent voisin
d'Essos où elle a trouvé refuge après la
mort de son père depuis l'assassinat du
roi fou par Jimy deneris nourrit
l'ambition de reconquérir la couronne et
de restaurer l'honneur de sa famille
elle la seule reine légitime dont la
légende raconte qu'elle est issue d'une
lignée de dragon mais chassé du royaume
et dépourvu d'armée denerist n'est pas
vraiment en position de revendiquer
quelque trône que ce soit c'est alors
que son frère va avoir une idée
organiser un mariage entre deneris et
caldogo le chef des doutraquis un peuple
de guerriers nomades qui pourrait
l'aider à renverser les lanister le
mariage a lieu daeris devient alors
officiellement la reine des d'autrequis
dans les premiers temps denériste n'est
pas à son aise parmi les deutquis leur
murs brutal tranch avec son éducation
royale et plus encore avec son désir de
venir en aide aux faibles et au démunis
quand elle voit la manière dont les
d'autqui traite les femmes et les
prisonniers elle intervient pour les
protéger faisant valoir qu'elle est la
reine et qu'à ce titre on doit lui obéir
retenez bien ça car c'est d'une
importance capitale pour la suite à
force de patience et de compromis daeris
finit par s'adapter à cette nouvelle vie
et au fil du temps elle parvient même à
gagner le respect de Drogo qui la
soutient désormais dans ses réformes
progressistes au contact de Drogo
deneris a gagné en assurance au contact
de deneris Drogo s'est adouci seulement
voilà cet adoucissement n'est pas du
goût de certains hommes de la tribu qui
voient en dééris une perturbatrice de
leurs tradition et de leur mode de vie
respecter les femmes bien traiter les
esclaves et les prisonniers voilà qui ne
correspond pas vraiment à l'esprit
d'autrequi Drogo va ainsi voir sa
virilité contestée et pour un autrequi
voir sa virilité contestée c'est voir
son autorité contestée à la suite d'une
confrontation durant laquelle il se
laisse enfoncer une pique dans la
poitrine pour bien montrer qu'il est le
chef et que le chef ne craint personne
Drogo Meur d'une infection dévasté
deneris ne saurait accepter un tel
destin pour l'homme qu'elle aime elle
sollicite alors les services du une
sorcière qui lui répond qu'elle peut
ramener Drogo à la vie mais qu'une vie
coûte une vie et que si deneris veut
qu'il ressuscite elle doit lui offrir
une vie en échange alors enceinte de
Drogo deneris n'hésite pas une seconde
elle sacrifie leur enfant à naître pour
le ramener à la vie le sortilège
fonctionne mais si Drogo est
effectivement vivant il est dans un état
végétatif bien loin du guerrier fier et
puissant dont elle est tombée amoureuse
ce n'est plus Drogo qui est là avec elle
mais l'ombre de ce qu'il fut certes elle
voulait que Drogo vive et il vit mais
vivre sans dignité ce n'est pas vivre
daeris décide de mettre fin à cette
parodie d'existence en étouffant Drogo
sous un oreiller le soir de ses
funérailles elle allume un immense
bûcher dans lequel elle place Drogo
ainsi que les trois œufs de dragon qui
lui avaiit offert à leur mariage alors
que les flammes consument le corps de
Drogo deneris entre dans le bûcher
semblant décidé à quitter le monde des
vivants au côté de son mari et c'est là
que l'inimaginable se produit tandis que
l'au se lève deseris s'émerge des
cendres vivant et dans ses bras trois
dragons la légende est confirmé
dénerérissit bien la mer des dragons
celle que les dieux ont désigné pour
régner sur westos l'élu dont l'heure est
enfin
venue reconnu comme reine par les de
deneris entame une série de conquêtes de
libération sur le continent des SOS
l'expression conquête de libération peut
sembler être une antithèse c'est
pourtant ce terme qui décrit le mieux la
double ambition de deneris libérer les
opprimés et étendre sa domination
étendre sa domination pour libérer les
opprimés à ce stade deneris envisage le
pouvoir comme un moyen la bienveillance
de deneris est perçue comme une
incongruité dans un monde régi par la
loi du plus fort y compris par ceux qui
la subissent sur le chemin de mirine
elle tente de donner à boire à un
esclave cloué sur une croix mais au lieu
d'accepter il l'a prie de le laisser
mourir quand elle achète l'armée des
immaculés pour marcher vers Westeros
elle les met face à un choix auquel il
ne s'attendait pas la suivre en homme
libre ou ne pas la suivre le maître mot
de deneris c'est la liberté on pourrait
croire que l'humanisme de deneris est
son point faible car il la rend
vulnérable face à des monarques bien
moins épriquel de justice et de liberté
mais en réalité les choses ne sont pas
aussi simples quand il s'agit des tyrans
des maîtres des oppresseurs d'Éris
n'affichent aucune pitié pour libérer
les Immaculés de la BA deser alors
qu'elle s'était engagée à payer leur
propriétaire elle le fait finalement
tuer par son dragon avant de demander
aux esclaves de mettre à mort tous les
maîtres amirine où 163 esclaves ont été
crucifiés elle ordonne la crucifixion de
163 m afin que tout le monde comprenne
que la vie d'un esclave ne vaut pas
moins que celle d'un mètre deneris rêve
d'un monde harmonieux et égalitaire un
monde où le pouvoir serait au service de
la liberté et du bonheur de l'humanité
et si ce monde nexiste pas alors elle le
créera la force de deneris c'est son
esprit révolutionnaire sa philosophie
l'idéalisme sa devise je briserai la
roue quand elle apprend que son père
n'était pas sur nommé le roi fou pour
rien et qu'il avait effectivement
l'intention de mettre le feu à sa propre
ville et d'en exterminer les habitants
deneris fait la promesse de ne jamais
lui ressembler son ambition être une
reine juste et humble qui ne fera jamais
passer ses désirs personnels avant
l'intérêt du
peupleeris veut briser la roue cette
roue c'est celle de l'oppression tous
les rois dans l'histoire ont opprimé
leur peuple et comme le rappelle Tyrion
tout souverain se doit d'inspirer un
minimum de crainte mais deneris ne veut
pas être un souverain comme les autres
elle ne veut pas se contenter de
succéder à son père elle veut faire
table ras des atrocités qu' a commise
prouver au monde qu'un dirigeant peut
être redouté par les puissants et aimé
par les faibles mais il n'est pas facile
de rester humble quand tout le monde se
prosterne devant vous le caractère
grandiose de chacune de ces victoires la
peur qu'elle inspire au tyran ainsi que
l'admiration qu'elle suscite auprès du
peuple comme de son entourage vont
progressivement influencer image que
deneris a d'elle-même elle se rend
compte de son pouvoir de transformation
sur le monde un pouvoir qu'il n'est pas
excessif de qualifier de surnaturel
puisqu'en plus de disposer de trois
dragons elle est immunisée contre le feu
quand ses proches parlent d'elle ils
utilisent tous le même mot il croi en
elle il croit en elle comme on croit
dans une divinité la grande beauté de
denéris en fait une femme convoitée par
cal Drago qui en a fait son épouse mais
aussi par Jora son chevalier servant
puis par Dario un mercenaire qui se
mettra à son service à sa façon deneris
aimera chacun d'entre eux mais c'est de
John snow qu'elle tombera véritablement
amoureuse John qui possède une qualité
que les autres n'ont pas celle de lui
résister celle de refuser de ployer le
genou devant elle tant qu'elle n'a pas
fait la preuve de son mérite celle de
faire passer son devoir avant elle de
plus en plus deneris est en quête
d'autorité être la use de chînne ne lui
suffit plus ce qu'elle veut désormais
c'est être reconnu reconnu comme une
libératrice reconnue comme la seule
reine légitime quand John lui fait
comprendre qu'il n'est pas impressionné
par elle cette attitude la séduit autant
qu'elle la dérange c'était déjà le cas
avec Drogo dont elle admirait
l'agressivité mais désirait la
soumission sans s'en rendre compte
daeris a pris goût à la popularité et à
ce qu'on s'incline devant sa puissance
alors que son pouvoir était initialement
un moyen de rendre la justice il semble
désormais que deneris ne rend la justice
que pour qu'on reconnaisse son pouvoir
le moyen et la fin se sont inversés ses
idéaux n'étaient finalement que le
masque de son ego pour qui s lire entre
les ligne les signes avant-coureurs de
l'orgueil de deneris étaient déjà
présents depuis le début de son
ascension son besoin de rappeler son
statut de reine des d'autres acquis à
chaque fois que ses décisions étaient
contestées son besoin de faire énumérer
ces titres à chacune de ses
présentations son intolérance à toute
forme de conseil qui n'irait pas dans le
sens de ses désirs ou de ses convictions
deneris a être une femme indépendante et
valeureuse elle n'en demeure pas moins
une personne susceptible et capricieuse
une fille de roi qui ne supporte pas que
les choses aillent dans une autre
direction que la sienne certes deneris
veut libérer les opprimés mais elle veut
surtout être celle qui libère les
opprimés derrière sa philanthropie ce
qui est à l'œuvre c'est un désir de
reconnaissance et un besoin de
gratification c'est là qu'apparaît
l'opposition fondamentale entre daeris
et Jon Snow John s'est toujours battu
pour l'honneur jamais pour la
reconnaissance son objectif a toujours
été de protéger son peuple jamais de
régé sur le royaume la quête de daeris
est extérieure celle de John est
intérieure daeris fait ce qu'elle pense
être la volonté des opprimés quitte à
aller contre la morale John fait ce
qu'exige la morale
quitte à aller contre la volonté des
siens ses ambitions étaient sans doute
moins grandes que Cell de deneris mais
en se tenant à distance du pouvoir il
s'assurait de ne jamais être emporté
dans son tourbillon ce tourbillon c'est
celui dans lequel deneris va sombrer
dans l'avant-dernier épisode de la série
alors que son armée se tient prête à
assiéger Port Royal deneris surgit du
ciel sur le dos de son dragon et
pulvérise la citadelle son regard
d'acier annonce qu'elle ne veut pas
seulement faire plier la l'armée de
cerseille mais la détruire et exterminer
jusqu'au dernier de ces hommes les
soldats de John s'engouffrent dans la
ville et se prépare à affronter la
deuxième ligne de combattants mais c'est
inutile devant l'ampleur des dégâts
causés par deseris l'armée de cerseille
dépose les armes la bataille fut de
courte durée et les choses auraient dû
s'arrêter là mais les choses ne
s'arrêtèrent pas là car quelques jours
avant la bataille cerseille a fait
assassiner missandi la proche
conseillère de
et cette ultime provocation fit
s'évaporer les dernières gouttes de
compassion qui coulaient dans les veines
de la mer des dragons à présent un seul
sentiment emplissait l'âme de deneris la
vengeance l'ennemi avait capitulé les
cloches de la rédition retentissait le
trône était libre mais deneris s'en
moquait aucune satisfaction dans ses
yeux mais une pure détermination à faire
pleuvoir le feu les cloches
n'annonçaient plus la paix mais le
châtiment son désir de protéger les
faibles venait de se dissoudre dans sa
soif de destruction détruire le monde
pour détruire l'injustice qu'incarne le
monde sans se rendre compte que
l'injustice c'est justement ça une ville
réduite en poussière des prisonniers
massacrés des enfants voyant leur mère
mourir avant de mourir à leur tour pour
que le monde comprenne qu'il n'y a
qu'une seule conception de la justice
celle de deneris et que quiconque s'y
opposera finira consumer par les flammes
de son dragon John assiste démuni à
cette scène d'apocalypse comment
pouvait-il réagir à ça lui qui refuse
d'être roi mais qui a fait le serment de
protéger son peuple lui qui ne veut pas
de la couronne mais qui refuse de
l'avoir porté par une reine sanguinaire
lui qui aime deséris mais qui ne la
reconnaît plus John comprend alors que
Tyon avait raison le devoir c'est la
mort de l'amour il fit alors la seule
chose que peut faire un homme juste en
accord avec son devoir empêcher ce règne
tyrannique d'advenir empêcher que ne se
perpétue la roue de l'oppression par
celle-l même qui avait juré de la briser
John tua deneris d'une lame de poignard
en plein ventre ce ventre dont les
derniers épisodes suggéraent qu'il
pourrai prochainement accueillir leur
futur enfant comme pour signifier que
cette mort n'est pas seulement celle
d'une reine mais d'un espoir Game of
Thrones c'est l'histoire d'un idé déchu
d'une aspiration à la justice broyée par
la grande roue de l'orgueil les êtres
humains sont ce qu'ils sont leurs idéaux
sont trop grands pour eux et si
l'histoire des hommes nous enseigne une
chose c'est que le poids de la couronne
se révèle parfois plus lourd que le
pouvoir du
bien roman film ou séries toute œuvre
narrative comporte ces personnages
principaux sur lesquelles repose
l'essentiel de l'intrigue mais les
personnages secondaires ont aussi leur
importance et il arrive de temps à autre
que certains d'entre eux offrent la clé
de compréhension du véritable sens de
l'œuvre les SEP personnages que nous
venons d'analyser font partie des
principaux mais qu'il nous soit permis
d'évoquer un 8e personnage au rôle
discret mais lourd en signification qui
pourrait bien éclairer d'un jour nouveau
le message profond de Game of Thrones 8e
personnage
varis surnommé le maître des
chuchotteurs varis opère dans l'ombre
son travail faire remonter au roi les
informations secrètes que lui fournit
son réseau d'espion ses petits oiseaux
comme il les appelle varis est au
courant de tout avant tout le monde et
il dépend de lui d'avertir le roi de ce
qui se trame ou de garder les
informations pour lui conformément à la
dage de little finger le savoir c'est le
pouvoir en cela c'est varis qui décide
quel pouvoir aura le roi tout au long de
la série il est difficile de savoir dans
quel camp se situe varis Barathéon
lanister targarien il a servi toutes les
maisons et il n'hésite pas à en changer
lorsqu'il sent le vent des événements
tournés notre réflexe premier pourrait
être de considérer varis comme un
opportuniste un mercenaire de
l'information sans idéologie ni
conviction prêt à trahir le roi en place
pour se vendre au plus ha franc mais ce
serait là une lecture bien superficielle
des choses ne se vend pas au plus offran
il se vend à celui en qui il croit
c'est-à-dire à celui qui lui paraît le
plus à même d'assurer le bien du royaume
les intrigues et les rivalités
politiques ne l'intéressent pas la seule
chose dont il se soucie c'est le peuple
ces centaines de milliers d'hommes de
femmes et d'enfants qui veulent juste
vivre dans la dignité et auquel personne
ne pense ces innocents dont on fait des
esclaves ces orphelins dont on fait des
criminels ces travailleurs qu'on prise
alors qu'ils sont le cœur battant de
chaque cité pour varis ce sont toutes
ces voix silencieuses qui ont de la
valeur et non les ambition de quelques
puissant en mal de reconnaissance varis
n'est pas un opportuniste c'est un
parvenu qui n'a pas oublié d'où il
venait comme il le dira ma véritable
loyauté ne se situe pas envers un roi
mais envers le peuple la qualité de
varis c'est la clairevoyance sa
philosophie servir le peuple sa devise
je pense au royaume il faut bien que
quelqu'un le fasse varis est un eunuque
autrefois comédien il fut vendu comme
esclave à un mage noir qui lors d'une
cérémonie occulte lui trancha les
parties génitales et les jeta au feu
varis vit alors le feu devenir bleu et
entendit une voix venue du ciel
s'adresser au mage depuis ce jour varis
croit au
surnaturel cet événement dont varis n'a
jamais évacué le traumatisme n'a pas
seulement pour fonction de donner une
consistance au personnage il est un
élément clé de son statut particulier
dans la série à plusieurs reprises dans
Game of Thrones le surnaturel s'invite
dans la réalité les marcheurs blancs
littéralement des morts vivants les
résurrections comme celle de Drogo ou de
John snow ou encore la vision à distance
et dans le passé pour Bran Stark devenu
la corneille à trois yeux la plupart des
personnages de la série ne croit pas
dans la réalité de ces choses avant de
les avoir vu on admet l'existence des
dragons et des géants mais s'agissant du
surnaturel c'est l'incrédulité qui
prévaut varis c'est l'exception il est
le seul à envisager que de telles choses
puissent réellement exister cette
ouverture d'esprit cette conscience que
tout est possible fait de varis un
personnage beaucoup plus prudent que la
moyenne prudent dans ses jugements
prudent dans ses décisions car c'est le
propre des incrédules de commettre des
erreurs qui leur seront fatales
confondant les limites de la réalité
avec les limites de leur esprit la
castration de varis est également un
élément chargé de signification sur le
plan symbolique la castration désigne la
perte de virilité et par conséquent de
l'instinct de conquête qui lui est
associé on trouve de nombreuses
allusions dans la série au fait que
c'est le désir sexuel qui est à
l'origine des guerres et des luttes pour
le pouvoir ce sera même dit
explicitement par Jamie au cours d'une
discussion philosophique de haute volée
avec Brown qui se conclura par ses mots
peut-être que tout ça n'est qu'une
histoire de queue Jamie sait de quoi il
parle lui qui a conscience que toute
l'histoire de Game of Thrones ses
centaines de milliers de morts ces
millions de coups d'épée et ces
éternités d'agonie ont pour point
d'origine un coï avec cerseille en tant
que nuque varry s'est affranchi de ce
désir son jugement n'est pas brouillé
par la pulsion sexuelle et par
l'instinct de domination qu'elle génère
il est une conscience pure et le terme
d'immaculé le décrirait parfaitement
s'il ne désignait pas des déjà les
combattants de la baie des dragons eux
aussi castrés afin de préserver leur
rationalité autre élément significatif
la fonction de varis maître des
chuchotteurs et le surnom de ces espions
ses oiseaux ces deux appellations
doivent retenir notre attention car elle
signale que varis est détenteur de deux
facultés il entend tout et il voit tout
autrement dit de par sa fonction varie
cette omniscient or si l'omniscience
c'est le pouvoir des dieux il est aussi
celui dont va hériter Bran Stark auquel
on a prédit qu'il pourrait voler une
allusion aux oiseaux qui depuis le ciel
ont vu surtout Bran est élu roi parce
qu'il met son omniscience au service du
bien avant Bran c'est varis qui occuper
cette fonction de là à dire que varis
avait toutes les qualités pour être roi
voilà une hypothèse dont votre réflexion
sera seul juge varis a cru en deseris et
en sa volonté de briser la roue de
l'oppression il y a cr cru jusqu'à ce
qu'il perçoive les premiers symptômes de
son instinct tyrannique ni Jora ni
Tyrion ni même John n'avait pressenti ce
que varis avait pressenti que daeris
n'était pas la reine qu'ils attendaient
quand varis comprend il décide
d'intervenir ne devenez pas ce que vous
avez toujours combattu dira-t-il à
daeris mais il était trop tard varis
aura beau tenté d'ouvrir les yeux à
Tyrion ce dernier refusera de voir la
réalité en face il n'y a pas plus
aveugle que celui qui veut croire il n'y
a pas plus clairvoyant que celui qui
voit ce qu'il ne veut pas croire pour
avoir voulu alerter Tyrion Var sera
exécuté et ses derniers mots seront
prophétiques j'espère m'être trompé il
ne s'était pas trompé et c'est pour cela
qu'il est
mort de nombreux fans de Game of Thrones
ont été déçus par la fin de la série à
savoir que John ne devient pas roi mais
cette déception nous auons pu l'éviter
en prêtant attention à cette parole de
varis qui constitue peut-être la phrase
la plus importante de Game of Thrones le
roi idéal est celui qui ne désire pas
être roi il ne le désire pas car il a
conscience que sa conception du bien lui
est propre et qu'il ne saurait l'imposer
au reste de l'humanité deneris voulait
faire le bien mais qu'en est-il des
autres qu'en est-il de tous ceux qui
pensent savoir ce qui est juste mais qui
pourtant ne sont pas d'accord entre eux
sur ce qui qui est juste la réponse de
deneris c'est qu'elle ne leur laissera
pas le choix elle autrefois si attachée
à la liberté la réponse de John c'est
que malgré son amour pour elle il en
empêchera en reprenant le chemin de la
gare de nuit John aura sans doute
frustré bon nombre de spectateurs mais
cette frustration contient un
enseignement fondamental sur lequel nous
devrions tous méditer comprendre qu'un
roi n'est pas la solution à tout
comprendre que le plus sage des êtres
humains reste faillible et que la seule
personne dans laquelle nous devons
placer desesoir c'est nous-même
vré pour un monde meilleur ce n'est pas
seulement déposer une couronne sur la
tête du plus vertueux c'est aussi et
peut-être même surtout s'inspirer du
plus vertueux et mener nos batailles
quotidiennes avec la même humilité le
même courage et le même dévouement que
celui qu'on voudrait voir sur le trône
incarner la vertu au lieu de l'attendre
des autres le message de Game of Thrones
c'est que si le monde était peuplé de
John snow nous n'aurions que faire des
jeux de
[Musique]
Trô